[cheers and applause]
[spooky music]
- In theaters this Halloween...
[screeching]
Comes a new vision of horror
like you've never seen before.
From the twisted mind...
of Wes Anderson...
[upbeat music]
It's "The Midnight Coterie
of Sinister Intruders,"
starring Owen Wilson
as a man in danger.
- Wow.
What the heck?
There's a bunch of crazy
people standing in our yard.
Hey, hon, I think we're
about to get murdered.
- And his terrified wife,
Gwyneth Paltrow.
- You don't say.
- Yeah, look at 'em all!
There's a guy
with a meat cleaver
and an old record player.
One's carrying a falcon.
There are twins in
matching track suits.
Hey, look at that.
Why, that's Danny Glover.
- Hello.
- A tale of handmade horror.
[fast violin music]
- Hey, they've sent us
some kind of communiqué!
- "Dear Homeowner...
"Can we kill you?
The Murderers."
- "Dear Murderers,
"No you may not!
The Homeowner."
Hey, kids, come on, let's
go to the panic room!
- We have to protect
ourselves, or we'll die.
- Quick, let's gather
all our weapons.
- Darn.
- We should've left sooner.
- With Tilda Swinton
as the town constable.
[knock at door]
- Hey, wow. We're saved.
- Who here are the murderers?
I see.
- "The New York Times"
calls it,
"You Had Me at Wes Anderson."
And "Fangoria" magazine
says, "Da Fuh?"
And Alec Baldwin
as the Narrator.
[thunder booms]
[bicycle bell rings]